i love underdogs i love being one ten
years ago
i'm in a liquor store saying i'm gonna
buy the jets
nobody believes you were saying it back
then oh i've got i've been saying it
since i was in
fourth grade oh my god well you're
really gonna do it then oh so you you
like that it's that
like you feel like the more yeah so so
so i loved it when i was a dnf
student and nobody could see it but i
knew i
loved it i loved it even a lot even six
years ago when
it looked like more that i was a loud
mouth motivational speaker like i liked
it
i almost even think that a lot of times
i sandbagged myself
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is gary vaynerchuk
better known as garyvee to everybody
else
huge following this guy is like such an
inspiration
is so direct so down the barrel has such
confidence and is a major business mogul
he started off turning his parents wine
company from
i mean he was like 22 years old from a
three million dollar company
12 years later with 60 to a million
dollar company and
now he's created a giant business for
himself that's so successful
he wants to buy the jets someday so with
the trajectory he's on
i'm sure that he will one because i
believe in goals and two is because he's
he just seems to have it put together we
talked a lot about that and what makes
him the man that he is today what makes
him the businessman that he is and what
makes him the boss that he is but
there's so much to learn
in this episode of just mindset
and how to achieve greatness in life and
then
also how to view it too like you know
letting go of attachments and
doing things that make you happy and
bring you joy and are really
fun and you know they just seem to work
out usually then enjoy this episode
how are you gary i'm well how you
hanging in
yeah i'm good i'm good quarantine's been
uh
challenging everything is flipping
upside down right i feel like what do
you think the point of all this
is like if you were to like pull back
and look at the scenario
of all the [ __ ] that's been going on
what is really happening
well i think um one society needed
a little bit of humble pie you know
that it's funny when you said that
that's where my mind goes um
i go into uh you know man i think
that people really lost track over the
last decade of like what's important
and keeping up with the joneses and how
many followers do i have and
you know so i'm an optimist um as you
get to know me better you're going to
see it's really it's
what i call practical optimism i'm not
delusional but i'm optimistic and i
think
you know my brain goes into places like
people got to reconnect with
relationships or
you know were home for a year with their
child instead of being
a working mom and feeling that guilt and
now they have this incredible time with
the kid
or or you know someone's parent was
destined to unfortunately
not because of covet for other reasons
pass away and they got six quality
months at the end
or they learned a new skill set or
realized
wait a minute eating dinner at the
dinner table is nice and we actually are
going to do this once a month
let alone it's a week or every day so i
i think when i look at it
i think that it's um everyone's gonna
spend all their time thinking about the
negative
and i'm i've been spending most of my
time thinking what are the post
positives as we go into back to real
life
and what does that even look like work
from home i think i'll give you an
example
i my most anxious moments are when i'm
in the office in new york
my child has a school function a play a
sporting event
and i'm running out to be there just in
the nick of time
because i'm running this thousand person
company and somebody grabs me and has
something to pour in and i'm like no no
i gotta go and
and then in the whole 30 minute ride
from midtown to the upper east side to
go to this thing
i'm anxious instead i already talked to
my admins i'm like wow life is gonna be
so
cool post coven i'm gonna be able to
leave an hour
earlier instead of half an hour earlier
i'll go to a starbucks
i'm comfortable now doing a meeting on
zoom on my phone
or you know or just doing and now i
won't have to feel that feeling
and wow why was i even feeling that
feeling i should have done this a long
time ago so like
it's the great it's absolutely the great
reset of our generation and now i hope
that people
treat it meaningfully and that doesn't
undermine the carnage and the sadness
and so much that has been going on
it's just that you either look forward
or you don't and
and so my great hope is that people have
learned things about themselves
and make meaningful adjustments even if
they're as small as what i just said
about
being in a coffee shop next to your kids
thing 30 minutes before it starts
and doing work because you're busy like
i am but not having to like sweat the
whole time in traffic if you're gonna be
on time what have you learned or did you
just name it
that was definitely mentioned getting
getting to your kids is sort of like
events a little sooner but
you know maybe from a business
perspective or you know you know
what has changed or what will what will
definitely change is
i you know i was born in the soviet
union i came here it's a very rags to
riches story
i grew up in a family business liquor
store business i really blew it up
it was all team it was all family it was
all best friends it was all come to work
it's all put in the hours
you know one thing i've always admired
um
about you we've never really gotten a
jam so i'm just gonna go right into it
because i love to tell people things
i've
absorbed i loved people that actually
knew you talking about your work ethic
but i think people you know people don't
know like people really underestimate
work ethic you know like like
like my notes on you and preparing and
getting ready and watching things and
yeah it's work ethic right and so um
i've always put that on a pedestal you
know i think over the last
decade i think work ethic became the
word hustle and hustle got demonized a
little bit
with mental health and things of that
nature and so i've been empathetic to
that conversation
and i've tried to use work ethic versus
hustle more
because i don't because that word has
not been manipulated yet into something
negative
i think it's important but i will tell
you the biggest thing i've learned is
work ethic is a human trait and whether
the person's in the office
or at home they're going to execute
against that and so
the biggest thing i've learned is we are
going to be a much more work from home
organization my company and many others
yeah and that's going to lead to a
higher quality of life for a lot of my
employees
because let me pay i like analogies and
stories like i just told so let me tell
another one
i have a lot of young employees um in
their mid-20s into their early 30s
tons of weddings and things of that
nature in their lives friends
i think about my great employees who
really serious about their careers so
they leave
for the place friday midday from the
office it's
again we're new york central we're in la
london singapore so big cities
they're rushing to the airport they're
stressed they get in late friday just in
time for the rehearsal dinner so they're
tired
they you know they they have the wedding
but the the next
sunday morning they're stressed because
they're going to stay for the breakfast
but they got to catch a flight because
they have to be in the office on monday
that's seeing sarah or rick right now
now they leave
thursday morning right with their
boyfriend they get to work from the
computer all day
now they've got thursday night to enjoy
maybe even with their boyfriend just
those two then the party comes in on
friday
they're working on zoom on that friday
midday but now they're calmly going
to the rehearsal dinner rested and
enjoying nashville
or already they have the nice wedding
sunday they can do the breakfast they
can even catch up with their old friends
sunday evening
and they fly back monday morning
probably on zoom on the at the airport
maybe even on the compute you know on
the on the plane as that infrastructure
gets better
and then they can even come into the
office monday or finish that off monday
at their apartment back in the office on
tuesday
that is a totally different quality
experience of your friend's wedding
than what i know i and many of my
employees have and many that
listen now live on that weekend and
whether that's a family
reunion whether that's visiting your
best friend that you desperately miss
post college for three years whether
that's a million other things
replace wedding with boys trip to golf
you know the daytona 500 you know the
super bowl like every single thing that
that sunday
to monday franticness that thursday
friday to saturday franticness
i think could be a totally different
experience and become five day trips
instead of two day trips that are much
more healthy and
equally productive at work i think
that's going to be a societal game
changer
i love that because to me
i'm hearing you talk about happy
employees
and happy employees tend to do better
work
and they tend to well happiness is
contagious it's also a workplace thing
whether you're on zoom or whether you're
next to somebody
but there's another thing that you were
talking about that you don't have as
part of your part of working for you is
there's no such thing as sick days
right like you can take as many or work
vacation days or anything like you can
be gone as
much as you want and so i kind of feel
like you're ahead of this curve
like you're ahead of the copic curve i
mean they're like let me give let me
give you
another thing because we did it six
years ago unlimited vacation policy
we learned by year three it wasn't
working as well as i wanted
there was a lot of people that were
scared to take vacation because they
didn't
they they're so structured they're so
used to school
that they actually turned it into a fear
thing and we're taking
less time really yes so now we have a
mandated
comma unlimited i'm gonna come work for
you
thank you i think uh i think um it's
really worked i think what you see
for everybody who's listening right now
that has more than you know 100
employees it's like well that's a little
crazy like what you'll learn is
two percent three percent will take
advantage of it and by the way you have
the information and you can decide to
let them go or have meaningful combos
uh 50 will kind of take that minimum of
three weeks they still need the
structure
i don't believe you i'm cynical i'm
scared i'm peer-based
and then another another 45 percent will
go four five and six and really over
deliver in the other 45 weeks that they
are in the office because of that
incredible flexibility
where does the fear come from why would
somebody not take
if they could do just as good of a job
and get everything done and take their
five-day wedding trips versus their
two-day wedding trips
why the hell wouldn't they just do it
parenting dna circumstance
you know freud stuff you know a lot of
humans are insecure
oh really on some level i believe that
everyone should experience what better
feels like that's why i love being cbd
i'm an investor and i swear by beams
products
which combine thc free cbd
with other high quality ingredients
theme was founded by two
former professional athletes matt and
kevin and
they just dropped a new product called
focus
it's a daily capsule that helps boost
your focus
all day long so visit beamtlc.com and
use the promo code
pretty intense for 15 off your next
purchase
that's beamtlc.com of course we all have
fear and insecurities um uh
the one that i most focus on is
what your relationship is with judgment
from other people
yeah to me the thing i spend all my time
on is
when somebody says you're beautiful you
take it to heart
when somebody says that you're smart do
you take it to heart
i think a lot about compliments because
i think compliments lead to insecurities
believe it or not i think it leads to
getting them getting them and really
overvaluing them early what ends up
happening is that becomes your
affirmation
so that when when it switches on you
and you start getting hate you are now
in a framework of overvaluing
feedback and so you actually became
susceptible to to
the negative the hate the feedback
because you overvalued the affirmation
and so i'm trying to
parent educate manage
communicate through a place of like try
to find some sort of
medium place you know you know be
humble when you're being complimented
and be strong when you're getting pushed
against
so if you were going to sit down and do
a review
i don't know if you do those or i don't
know if you're going to sit if you you
need to talk to somebody
what is your approach for the framework
or the balance of delivering
the news that you need to do and maybe
honestly maybe it's a
one of the other right it could be
giving them props for the
kick-ass work that they've been doing
and this is good or it could be the
other side of it where you're like look
you're a problem and you need to fix
this like how do you approach that from
a balance standpoint
back to strengths and weaknesses as a
communicator
in public domain on a great podcast like
this in front of 20 000 people on stage
through the thousands of pieces of
content i put out every day and week and
month
i'm unbelievably good at this candor
practical but sweet like kindness but
truth right that's why i think
i've resonated as an operator
this has been a historical shortcoming
of mine i'm still working on this
in my 20s and 30s as a boss
positive feedback i'm the greatest
[ __ ] cheerleader of all time
i'm my mother you know i will you open
the door
to somebody you say thank you in a nice
you're a c player but you you try
i will cheer you like a son of a [ __ ]
candor like hey danica you know
you're like you're struggling like
you're not good at this the employees of
this
i was atrocious at believe it or not
because on instagram
and on podcast i look like this great
straight shooter and i
am i am when it's when i'm not talking
to a human
when i'm talking about it to the macro
but on a human versus alone so correct
killed what's the difference tell me how
can that
what would you feel as a difference i
could see your face
and i don't like negativity or hurting
someone's feelings
i the compassion and empathy would take
over
too much and i think you know my dad was
the other way my mom and dad are
opposites on this my dad really
does not have empathy or compassion or
sympathy he for others
that's his own thing you know he he's a
great guy but he doesn't know how to
he actually he has it he doesn't know
how to communicate it let's put it that
way
my mom is the other direction like
literally every single human's favorite
person
so much of my charm and good stuff comes
from that but she
she like me will hold in her actual
feelings
i had the fortune and unfortunate
aspect that layered on top of this as
human tree
i was a business operator from day one
so i could be
sweet and affirmative and and
and this positive energy but i was
required to fire
otherwise my business would go out of
business and so what ended up happening
danica in my 20s
into my early 30s and i would argue that
it was my younger brother aj when we
started working together at vaynermedia
11 years ago when i was 33 he
he had much better ability to be
candorous
and i got to see firsthand the value in
it
and so for a long time in my career and
i would still argue that
publicly i'm a 10 of 10 with balance of
candor and kindness
and and probably it's not as some people
are turned off by my cursing and a
little bit too much alpha male so
i would even say like the candor
probably resonates even more in social
and
i think people that really dig in or
like oh wait a minute this guy's kind of
like sweet and
they don't see it at first sometimes
they have to really get into my content
i'm sure as you were doing i saw the
notes as you were probably doing the
homework you're like oh he's got a lot
of soft
like you start healing more of that
stuff
um but in in real life as a
co i'm still probably a 6.5 out of 10
which is a
far cry from a 1 out of 10 that i was 15
years ago
i still struggle more with telling a
direct report senior executive you stink
or i don't like what you're doing um and
i need to continue to get better at that
i value it i i hate that it's you know i
hate
i i wish i continued to work at getting
better at it
um so to answer your question a 10 out
of 10 if it's positive stuff i
i seek people out to give them positive
feelings
that's wonderful when i'm doing reviews
or having a real conversation
i still am anxious an hour before i have
to deliver bad news to that person
i feel like every one of your employees
should literally like listen to that
little clip and hear how much
although i'm sure that you they can feel
how much you care which is why you've
grown into this gigantic media company
and
are so successful but it leads me to
this thought about i've always felt like
this that there's two kinds of
two kinds of bosses there's one that
works out of fear and one that works out
of love
i'm gonna say this i i feel like
obviously we're pulling
deep deep polarities of of being a boss
but
i'm like i feel like you
balance that pretty well like you're
extremely down the barrel
but i can feel which again i don't know
you i can feel that it's because you
believe in them
it's because you want to see them
succeed and so
because i think the world is abundant i
don't think i i feel
you know also talent plays into this i
i am talented at business and i've
always been even as a
literally like a six-year-old child so
i don't i have this incredible
relationship with employees which is i
don't
need anything from them and i and to
your point
i have this analogy that is absolutely
love and fear
the way you have it i i call it you can
there's two ways to build the biggest
building in town one
just build the biggest building in town
the other is tear down everybody else's
building
and i find that deeply insecure people
tend to also find ways to success
because they're just like they use that
energy however
they as leaders manifest into one of
those individuals that
tears down everybody else wow so draw
that out
like do a trajectory on each boss
because i'm sure people listening are
like
dude i definitely have a boss that works
out of fear like i do not want to
disappoint
yeah that boss or the one out of lab
which there's pitfalls for that
they are they're absolutely i mean the
biggest negative feedback i get when i
get third party
anonymous reviews as a boss is that i
don't fire people fast enough
so like that's loving too much right
like i'll go into therapist mode instead
of boss mode
and then the problem is that person's
not performing so the other a players
are frustrated by that
yeah and i respect that i i believe that
is a flaw
but it's a flaw i'd rather have than the
alternative yeah
yeah um now
so unpack it it's simple it is
absolutely predicated on how one was
parented the dna they were gifted and
where they grew up
this is well documented and i think the
bosses that
rule with fear were raised in fear are
scared themselves
i think that leadership is the mirror of
what's in someone's soul
and so that's how i see it i mean it's
just so cliche i
i struggle very little with auditing
somebody pretty quickly once i get to
actually spend time with them
it's all quite basic uh you know the
circumstances are always different
sexual abuse as a child you know uh a
mom that was insecure
you know uh you know there's a million
different things
and and people take adversity and you
know one of the tale you know we have a
lot of people that grew up with tough
parenting
but their dna they actually got from the
grandma or the grand
the great aunt and so they actually
looked at that adversity and went the
other way
you know people fall into different
camps here so you know i try to train up
my leaders
what i do is i try to make my leaders
feel safe and then
that in turn usually manifests in them
making their people feel safe but
the world you know is absolutely based
on leadership
like everything stems from the top
you've been on you know
on teams obviously your sport you grew
up in has some individuality and has
some teams
dynamics it's unique in that way but
you've seen it firsthand you've been on
enough different scenarios where
even the brands you've worked with like
it's just black and white this is
absolute life is about casting
it is the humans in charge
that trickle down um and i see it in
sports
which i have a lot of passion for and i
see it in business where i have a lot of
passion for it i've seen a parenting
which i have a lot of passion for so
it's the same game everywhere your dad
what would you
what do you try and teach your kids that
you think will
put them in accountability position
accountability
i think the biggest fear i have is my
kids are much more fortunate than i was
so ramifications accountability the the
biggest thing is kindness
the number one thing i think about is
teaching kindness i i
i'm very excited i actually
know i can see it this is what i'm good
at that kindness
is starting to be understood as a
and i think that um you hear a lot of
people saying like
well i stopped being kind when i was
getting walked all over and it makes me
laugh
because i've never
i i do not i'm not a pushover
and i'm kind i think that people blend
things together for example i have a
dear friend who's like
gary nice guys finish last this and that
and we had a dinner once
and i really broke it down for him over
four hours it was a one conversation
and i said friend because i don't want
to call him out i said friend
now that we've talked about this for two
hours let's get to the truth the truth
is
you're not being kind in the examples
you gave me you're being manipulative
you're you're letting somebody walk all
over you as a
trap to get what you actually want and
oh by the way
the things you just described of being
walked all over you actually don't value
those things
it's kind of like when people tweet at
me when i'm like i'm coming to naturally
give a talk and i'll get a bunch of
people and be like
yeah i want to do you a favor let me
give you a ride to your hotel
you don't want to give me a ride you
want to pick me up and you want to ask
me questions for 40 minutes which i'm
by the way i am flattered to no end
it's just that i'm working 18 hours a
day and then taking a play i just need a
moment to catch up with my family
and maybe rest yeah so what i said to
this friend i said you're not being
walked all over
you're manipulating you're trying to get
something out of that person
you're letting them quote unquote walk
all over you because you're planning on
asking for something
and oh by the way you're letting them
walk all over you by giving them
something that they're not even asking
for
and then you're gonna ask for something
by giving something that the person
didn't even ask for
and then i think you know you know
without knowing you but just knowing of
you and knowing the life you lived
it's just impossible that you haven't
navigated your point in your life now
where you've felt from the other side
people
trying to give you something you're not
asking for with 100
intent for asking for something after
the fact
and that's not being walked all over by
danica patrick that's trying to
manipulate a situation for your own self
once that's very different than being
kind
and not being a pushover yeah
oh i've experienced tons of times where
people let me help you out let me do
this and you're like yeah so that you
can ask for something later
that's way bigger that's it
i'm like i'll pay for everything along
the way
that's it let's just keep it clean
have you been taking advantage i mean
like do you can you think back and like
at their time because you can see the
way i
no because you can see the way i
articulate i'm so
kind of like clean my ability to
communicate is my great strength
so when i see it brewing and i actually
like the person
i'll make like a joke i'll be like okay
carl we're gonna do this thing but
i'm just being really upfront with you
buddy in six months when you ask me to
invest in your startup you know that's
not going to happen because your startup
sucks
and then hahaha and then what happens is
eight or ten times that person will
retreat
all of a sudden this miraculous thing
they wanted to give me is gone two out
of ten times i find someone like myself
which lives completely on karma
actually enjoys the process of giving
subconsciously
and consciously knows something good
might happen but is not crippled
if something good doesn't happen hmm
they're not attached
they're not attached that's actually a
good place to go
i have this i have this syndrome a
little bit i have a little bit of
destination syndrome a little attachment
to outcomes and how things go um
i would say i feel like a lot of people
are sort of like people that either look
in the past or they look in the future
presents pretty hard but we all linger
in there here and there but we but i
feel like people tend to be
future or past thinkers and i'm a future
thinker but
so which is a great thing because i
manifest like crazy but i
but i get a little attached at times to
outcomes it's so funny we are so
similar except for one thing i have no
attachment to outcomes
even when i talk about my dream of
buying the new york jets i always try to
clarify to people
i just like trying to buy the new york
jets
i've heard you say that i'm attached
yes the joy's in the journey for sure
man god gosh i wish there was a way to
translate chemicals
in your body in a moment to the audience
when i tell you the warmth like that
like
delicious happy feeling that i just felt
thinking about the fact that i'm 44 and
i'm gonna have 40 years to really try to
put this puzzle together
it's just amazing i will have no i will
not be sad in
any shape or form if i'm unable to
achieve this professional goal
because the happiness of trying the
chase is everything
there's got to be a little more to that
little more could the chase be
because you know that having a lofty
goal of buying a billion dollar
you know sports team means that you're
going to have to get to that point
so you're like i can't wait to see what
happens from now until then because
you know i think you only get halfway
there and then you know i'll give you my
best answer
no because i when i tell you my gives a
flux for money
is zero no but i will tell you this and
i'm going to say it in a very weird way
the only time i rooted for tiger woods
and kobe bryant
rest the soul was when nobody
else did
i loved being an underdog
i love underdogs i love being one the
and i think that what i've been able to
figure out in the last three or four
years
it and it's pretty recent is like right
if i make this insane go you know one of
the worst things that's going on with me
is that things are going well
professionally and
people are start you know 10 years ago
i'm in a liquor store
saying i'm going to buy the jets nobody
believes you were saying it back then
oh i've got i've been saying it since i
was in fourth grade
oh my god well you're really gonna do it
then oh so you you like that it's that
like you feel like the more yeah so so
so i loved it when i was a dnf student
and nobody could see it but i knew i
loved it i loved it even a lot even six
years ago when
it looked like more that i was a loud
mouth motivational speaker like i liked
it
i almost even think that a lot of times
i sandbagged myself
a little bit to keep the game over the
but you know a couple weeks ago i sold
con you know empathy wines to
consolation it was a lot
congratulations i'm in the wine business
so i just know how big constellation
brands is and that's just
and obviously then coming from the
background of being a kid
you know so yeah so
you know it's so fun to talk to somebody
that's accomplished
such unique things because without
knowing everything because i don't you
know i don't know this part about you
but
i also am similar i'm like there's no
way she did what she did
without dreaming those dreams early on
it's just too hard
it's just too hard because there's so
much that goes into getting there
um so for me i love being an underdog
um i resonate with underdogs
i only like up i unless the person plays
for my favorite team
and they're an all-time player i usually
hate them because i don't like that
they're on another team
i only like them when they're washed up
you know
like like i only can root for them when
they're washed up
back to like you know when tiger was
hurt or where kobe was in his last scene
michael came back michael jordan came
back
he's different because i'm a die-hard
knicks fan i've played michael jordan my
whole life and still do to this second
tom brady and michael because the jets
and knicks will never get my love
as a fan but nonetheless i think
i love i love your your interview style
by the way
i like that you pushed on what's behind
that
so i want to give you my cleanest answer
my cleanest answer i think is my deep
love for the underdog i associate
so deep with it there's nothing more
delicious
you like that guy do you feel like that
guy 100 yeah
yeah 100 i mean i was right i was
you know i was a terrible student you
know for i mean look i i'm 44 i was born
in
russia the soviet union i was born in
belarus but it was known as russia slash
ussr
when i'm in second third fourth grade
we're the enemy friends
friends and definitely non-friends pick
on me razz me um
i i i'm not physically gifted so i was
after sixth grade where because i have
great hand-eye coordination so
you know i'm up for any of those kind of
games with anybody but
once true physical stature became a
variable
that went away i was an atrocious
student so here i am by 13
12 11 and the world teachers coaches
other friends moms the world has pegged
me into losing player
and i went into a very good this is
where my mom comes in parenting my mom
on the flip side in my four walls in my
home i'm the greatest
with but with circumstances so she
didn't delusion me like a lot of kids
now
like i'm the greatest but when i got a
bad grade i got grounded i'm the
greatest but if god forbid it wasn't in
my ethos
but if i was disrespectful she'd punch
me in the face russia style like
like so there was but i was the greatest
like kind
everything that i am like literally gary
vee is the manifestation of tamara
vaynerchuk like guaranty the character
on social
is 100 and by the way for clarity to
this audience
when i say the character on social that
is me that is fully me i don't play
something on
social it's that when i'm in a public
setting
or when the camera's on yeah i'm sure
everybody will recognize this
you're a different version of yourself
when you're with your loved ones when
you're at work
we have eight versions of ourselves that
guy is
my mom's doing like positive
reinforcement
work ethic kindness um so
you know at the end of the day i think
that
i really want to continue to be
underestimated because
the i told you so even though extremely
vain and quite
literally not that interesting it's so
funny we're talking such heady nice
things
it's it's a very kind of trite kind it's
not a very attractive
trait but i'm but you're putting me in a
very comfortable
authentic place here i love proving the
system wrong i love it
i love it i like you don't think like
you know who i would have
you know why i love novak djokovic and i
i met him recently during cove we
thought we can't friendly
and i said i love him because
i love when he's center court wimbledon
finals
and he's playing roger federer and
nobody
is cheering for him and
except for me and the people that are
listening right now that are wired like
us
yeah and he'll have a shot inevitably in
those matches
he'll have a shot and he does this thing
this is literally i couldn't wait we got
on zoom together
for the best time and i it took me i was
like let me save this to the end let's
get to know each other but within the
first five minutes i was too excited
and i painted him this whole scenario i
said no that
you were literally one of my favorite
athletes in the world for a
very narrow very narrow thing it's when
you're playing roger federer
at wimbledon center court not only
everybody there but the whole world is
rooting for roger
and you'll do some ridiculous shot
against an impossible shot from roger to
begin with
and you'll just take a step back and
look at everybody
and i know what you're doing which is
[ __ ] you totally
kind of look like what he's going to say
now and and honestly
the silence is golden you know you're
such a you know
you know you're such a competitor
because you just couldn't get to like i
don't know what your version is
i don't know what your friend's versions
are but i [ __ ] know it
and i love it i live for it yeah i'm
gonna i love the underdog too
but like not everyone is there so i
guess like from a fundament from a
standpoint of accomplishing great things
like how do you right how the hell
do you set the world on fire in business
and accomplish great things
and you know whether it be money or acu
you know
accumulating things or good people or
whatever like
what does it take right you're motivated
by being the underdog and i guess
essentially without those words saying
proving people wrong but i mean people
have told me that forever and i wouldn't
say that i like
wanted to prove people wrong as much as
i wanted to show them
show them who i was yeah i think i think
that's a great
and honestly same thing right like like
honestly like to me sometimes
in life on great shows like this we get
into semantics
there's a we are humans and we want to
communicate it's
it's you know i want to prove them wrong
and yet i don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
thinks about me so
there's a contradiction there it's
balancing all these energies
i think let me throw something out there
that i think is practical
i believe that the biggest missing
ingredient for a stunning percentage of
the people listening
right now is patience
i would you know when i hear you ask
that question you know
my brain likes to go fast and the first
thing right away was patience
you know i was i think i'm going to be
one of the great entrepreneurs of all
time
and at 29 years old i'm in my dad's
liquor store
ringing people up at the register and
carrying boxes to their
car during the holidays because we're
busy that level of patience and humility
to know who you are and at 29 when
society's like you're almost 30 have you
got your life figured out all this [ __ ]
that the kids
are stressed about i do think patience
was one of my secret
sauces um and i think it's something
that people could
put on a post it and start to try to
practice
just like getting into better health you
know you've got to do actions i think
the same thing with mental
strength you need to start practicing
things and you need to
you know i think when people are goal
oriented i always get scared when they
put a time frame on it now
athletes i have to be empathetic for
right you know because if you want to be
uh
you know a golfer or a quarterback or or
a tennis player like
it's kind of hard to say i'm gonna be
the best in the world at 44. there is
some physical truths
i was lucky that my craft i could be 69
when i'm at the pinnacle of my business
vacuum
and career so you know i want to be very
um empathetic that there are some
physical things that go along with some
people's hopes wants and dreams
but i think ultimately all of us
really want to be happy and it's super
cliche like
i i think we all want to be happy i
think we have to be careful to not be
happy
with a layer of delusion like the world
is real there's consequences
you have to put in work but i do think
patience is a big one
i also think did you learn that did you
learn that no
no i think that no i got lucky with that
one and when i say lucky
the dna you've been gifted with has i
did not tell my parents to have sex at
the moment they did
to make me so i do think i was gifted
fortunate that patience
felt like a real foundational thing for
me but i do think it came from the
underdog thing a little bit right like
if the world tells you sucks
you almost have to lean into like i'm
going to show you which means like you
got to be in
to patience a little bit i think the
other thing
you think everybody everybody starts as
an
underdog a little bit at the beginning
well you know what everybody
i'm not sure about that let me explain
what i mean by that i do think
very this is why i have a very funny
argument so i came up
very humbly so i have a lot of friends
who live extremely
simplistic financially challenging lives
with my dear friends
and so i'm a great i'm very grateful for
the mix you know
i i get invited to do something like
this with you which is really cool
and i and i mean that and i get to like
my
some of my best friends literally make
thirty four thousand dollars a year
wildly happy
and that's their life and i i'm i'm
grounded in a lot of arenas
they always get mad when i go here like
i'm already sure i'm going to get a fret
uh
i'll give the initials rt i know you're
about to text me if you listen to this
and you will
when i talk about being deeply
compassionate to kids that come from
high net worth
or famous parents you know i would argue
that a child
i'm trying to think of like a good power
like i don't know if if
blue ivy or you know i don't know
beyonce and jay-z's
child starts as an underdog and i think
that a lot of people
and obviously that's an extreme version
let's just go to the cliche
high net worth unbelievably capable
mother and father
like wonderful like that child is not
starting from underdog and i actually
think it's led to
deep unhappiness for the stunning
majority of those children
i think too much too soon
and what i would call a no-win situation
for a lot of kids puts them in a very
sad place and i would argue that
that's like i would never trade my life
with my children's life i mean that
and that's difficult to say but i'm
telling you the truth i don't
i you know so you know and so of course
except for everybody's listening that's
why a lot of my friends who grew up
crappy and are
you know like uh well guess what i'll
take that let you know and i get it i'm
empathetic to it but
i think the older you get the wiser you
get
the more exposed to real life you get
the more you realize
what money's relationship is with human
beings and it's like there's a lot of
great things
money does absolutely create freedom in
a lot of ways
but someone who's not
constrained to money actually has the
most freedom and so
you know i think there is nothing
everything is possible
it's super real and daniel you know this
because i'm sure
just knowing a little enough like just
projecting what you've gone through in
your life
you know you've seen other successful
people who
get trapped in their lifestyle and are
actually like would have been better off
being half as successful because it
would have been some flexibility they
start spending money
because it's like kind of good right
like a having privilege or having things
that are like
pretty good it kind of stunts your
growth in a way that you
settle almost that's right it becomes a
jail
for a lot of people like keep keeping up
with the one that kills me is keeping up
with
jones's when i go to like a dinner party
of eight couples and i can tell one
person is insecure of their status i
immediately change the entire direction
of the dinner
the whole night and then literally two
out of four times
because i'm pretty brave that way we'll
reach out to that person and try to
build a friendship
singularly to try to get them to never
compare themselves again
yeah yeah it's my great passion
with my content talking about passion
but and you're talking about money
you're talking about you know achieving
things but i kind of wonder
you know there's the underdog thing but
i don't know is there something a little
bigger that you feel like you have a
purpose
for boy you're doing a good job
um i don't want to lie
and i hate you know i'm really good at
answering questions so
i hate that you're asking me because
it's going to take me to a little bit of
a audacious place
but there has not been many days i've
lived my life that i didn't know
that i had something so
now it's okay to say that you i have a
concept of things you have
you have room to say that about yourself
look i think everybody you know i set it
up good news when i didn't have room to
say it when i was 20 i would say it to
my friends back then too
now what i don't know and i really don't
know
is did my mother completely create that
like was in her affirmation and
parenting style we're so close my mom
was 20 when she had me
we immigrated to america together my dad
worked every minute
you know that we got here to make it so
like my mom and my
relationship is i'm borderline getting
emotional right now it's
deep as [ __ ] and then that person's
telling you you are the [ __ ] best
but again i'm gonna say it again because
i know a lot of parents are listening
but
didn't let me go into delusion because i
see a lot of kids go there like when i
lost i lost
i remember coming up with this i was
really good at baseball again before
you know you needed to have power took
over and you know
and i remember trying to come up with an
excuse about the sun hitting my eye when
john longo john longo in edison new
jersey in the 80s
if anybody knows that character give him
a shout out he was a really
quality pitcher and i was like hitting
everything back then
and i he really struck me out like three
times in this one game
and i remember getting in the car and
trying to make an excuse about the sun
hitting my eyes
and i don't even think i got to the word
eyes
when my mom in russian sternly to a
nine-year-old me
said get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
so like this so so i'm just so great i
what you're hearing everybody is a 45
minute manifestation of
deep gratitude to circumstances and my
appearance
but yes i've always felt like i could
[ __ ] change the world i've absolutely
felt it
and in the last couple years i'm like oh
the internet was destined to come along
when i was here
had this not existed i would have never
made the impact that i've made because i
also
want to operate businesses and i love my
family and i didn't want like
it's just perfect timing for me
and um and i have a lot of
gratitude that i want to spread i've
been gifted with this incredible ability
to communicate
at the right time in the right way and
uh yeah i feel like i have a humongous
purpose i want
i want every person that ever meets me
to come to my funeral because i made
such a significant impact on them
to inspire them i have always said
you can find old videos of me of like i
live my life completely based on one
mission
how many people are coming to my funeral
and the reason i say that is the
following
i'm now 44 and i know what funerals i
was willing to miss
for work or family and that is because
even though that person was a good
business associate
or something else they didn't pierce my
soul
and i know the couple of weird ones that
people were confused why i
quote unquote maybe went hey gary wait
my mom like i didn't know you were that
close to x y and z
it's because a singular conversation or
moment
pierced my soul and so
i want to be so valuable
to people um and
and i and i believe that when i die
hopefully in my late 90s or early 100s
with
advancements of medicine that when 77
year old ricky in arizona hears that
that he's gonna
schlep to new york or new jersey and and
uh and come to that funeral i mean that
that's
how i want to live my life and i and and
i i think
it depends if you're listening to this
on the other side
this is what's always fascinating about
the way i communicate to me about me
i always wonder what the other person
you know if you're cynical
that just came off audacious
if you're not cynical you think about
that statement you say wow that's kind
of neat
because this is how i feel about people
that have similar sentiment
that's nice you you know you want to be
nice and good
so that people come and so that's how i
think about my life
i'm gonna i'm gonna go there
um i actually did this some i
some while back maybe within the last
year something came up about
writing your own eulogy and so i did it
because i wanted to reverse engineer my
life to how i should live now
based on how i want to be remembered and
so
take a stab at your eulogy can you do
that
i can and you know where i just went
uh as i looked out and beyond if you're
watching you just saw me look out i was
listening
i'm a big fan of doing very big
oh you know i think people pontificate
and they they
are insecure so they make up things like
well i'm a perfectionist that's why i'm
not doing it
which is just code for i'm scared about
what people are going to think
um and i was i never heard of anybody
writing their own
that hasn't hit my radar i'm sure in
passing but it never
struck me like you were just talking and
the reason i just looked away was
oh i do that every day
i it's so funny you just said that
i realized right just like so much of
what makes me successful professionally
i don't put it pen to paper but i talk
about it with myself on a daily basis
that's why
what i just ranted about five minutes
ago is what i was ranting about
it is so top of mind for me
that my great dream uh you know that i
think about admiration i think about
what people say i care about my
reputation
i i treat everybody in a nice way it's
it's my framework
i write it every day in my mind it's
it's my f there's two things i do pretty
consistently
how do i be so nice and good that this
is good
and what would happen if somebody that i
love died today
i do that almost every day those two
thoughts run through my mind every
single day
the reason the second one happens is
because i think it leads to my
perspective
if i lost all my businesses i always say
to myself what if i was on the i used to
do this in my 20s
i did this a lot actually if i was on
the cover of time magazine at man of the
year
and i bought the jets that day
but an hour later somebody called me and
said my sister was in a traffic accident
died
what would happen and the answer is the
other two things
would matter so little it's not even in
the same [ __ ] universe
yeah so why don't i live my life that
way
and what that did was it created a
framework where
the pressures of what i do
professionally i just don't get that
upset about
business it's like a game huh
it's like a game and i'm
so like good at like i'm good at feeling
so i can really go there like
i can really it's super weird how
powerful the brain is sometimes i can
really feel the gut punch
of my sister calling me hysterically
crying mom's dead
like and it like like to the point where
i'm like crying on like like
literally misting in an airport because
i'm thinking that way
it is my it is my great
prescription to happiness perspective of
what actually matters
and i and i think it's a nice tie back
to kind of how i opened this rant
this combo right i hope people have used
covid to reframe
you talk you just said the power of the
mind and then you said you feel it your
body and so
i go down a lot of these roads about
quantum physics and
consciousness and how all this stuff
works creating your reality and so
then when you layer in your mom's strong
subconscious programming of you are
great you made a mistake
or try harder or i'm so proud of you
you can do this like the programming
subconsciously which shoot people
listen to subconscious programming while
we while they sleep
i have before like i mean it's
incredibly powerful
but i think of this um i think of this
mind
this this when you think something then
you
feel in response to the thinking
and then that pre pre that creates a
hormone and then the subconscious gets
really good
at looping that and you have created
like a really good system where you loop
the right hormones that keep you in a
positive
place 100 but not everyone does
how like you must see this in the
workplace you must see this with people
and do you have advice for people that
you see potential in but then you look
at them and you're like
yeah okay so you're bringing yourself
down here and you're
you're cheating yourself of what you
could accomplish is there a mission you
send them on to go
here's your rehab yes
and uh but i by being an a and uh by
being excuse me a dnf
student um i'm in a place
where
i'm not structured enough to put them
into that process i put it into an
osmosis process
so when i when i see them i surround
them with the human beings
that are good at the thing so i'm
off of my talents or and shortcomings i
want everybody to hear this
i'm not going to create training
programs
like i don't like the the opera like i
love ops but i don't like um
kind of like do like i don't like the
standard things
right like companies like what they do
and and that my framework to that
question is i see it much more in
companies with friendships in real life
i just
lean into the relationship so i have
such great relationships i like to try
to really lean in
ironically that's why doing work too
instead of creating like
oh go to these classes in the middle of
the day or we're going to bring in this
training program i think a lot of people
do things it's kind of like diversity
and inclusion they do things to check
the box optically but they don't
actually give a [ __ ]
and for me so
for me with the employees what i try to
do is i try to actually make their
day-to-day
staffing be around
individuals that are winning that game
and i'll go into a conversation or two
with that employee and say look
i'm seeing this and i think you can win
this game and by the way you should
spend time with kalyn
or nick or lisa b you know and and um
that's how i go about it more on a the
answer is 100
it's a people game to me more than like
read this book
or take this course you set them up for
success
yep and set them up for success so how
do you know if you're in the right job
or the wrong job i feel like there's
probably
millions of people out there that listen
and be like
you know i want to go work for gary
um but but they they're probably
thinking like
i'm not super inspired but i kind of i
like what i'm doing
i don't know i i it all comes down to
what's your relationship with monday
wednesday and friday
so here's my point of view on your
question
how much do you hate monday morning
number two do you use the term
hump day do you like think about it like
does it actually hit your radar
uh and then friday do you live for it
because if you live for friday
because you can't wait for saturday and
sunday you're vulnerable now
of course you should be pum i'm pumped
for friday
but i also love monday and i don't even
like i've never thought about wednesday
in hump day termina i never even know
it's wednesday it's usually tuesday or
thursday or the day you know like
i'm too much enjoying it so
i think it's i think the answer to your
question is what's going on with your
monday wednesday and friday what is the
relationship
with monday wednesday and friday wow
what a really good simple guideline
thank you right yeah i like it right i
feel like i'm always looking for an
employee
it's so hard because you know you have
hundreds of them but uh i have just a
couple
and i like to call them people that work
with me um but i
i always say that i want someone that
works with me
that doesn't have a clock and a day
at all on there as somebody who also has
a small team around him as well
above and beyond that's a 100
on you thing that it's my responsibility
to make 100 like that 100 not even 99.
that's exactly right
let me explain because i'm excited right
now i think i might be able to like
really help
yeah um when you have a small team and
you're someone like you
there's an ungodly amount of people that
would love to be your admin
project manager creative like like a
pretty substantial list
which is huge which and the reason and
by the way
if you were somebody less known i
wouldn't say it's 100
on you but with you i am let me explain
why the pool
of humans that would take this job is
extraordinarily high
what that means is you're actually going
to be able to find somebody dna wise
so the only variable to you getting what
you want
is your management style
the management style for someone like
that is
you need to make them feel equally
that they never have to be on the clock
or they're allowed to always be on the
clock
if you talk to drock or andy k or tyler
some of my inner circle
alex raffington alexander is amazing
like
you know if if you talk to them i
guarantee that they would say we're
always on
but if i needed to take four months off
i know i can have it and there'd be no
ramifications
in that sentence is the key they know
they can go 13 hours hard
they know they if they text me and say
hey i need i need to do this
there's never and i mean there's never a
time
where i put myself in front of them
as long as they communicate that they
need it otherwise it's defaulting that
they're helping
yeah that data go that so is that
healthy
is that a healthy management style i
think so
i think i look at you know i think um if
you're if you're you know what ends up
happening is
you find human individuals there that
they feel safe because they
if they want to go hard for three years
to build up reputation
and then build their career off of it
they can it you know
i think they if they if they know
they're safe if you got their back
you know lack of fear is amazing yeah i
think it's i think it's
very very healthy for people that like
freedom
yeah i think it's concerning
to some who bought too deep into the
school system
and need structure like if they may hear
that from you and say no no
no i want to work nine to six and
another you know
and so i think it's the healthiest
version
it's a relationship built on truth
and trust yeah uh and practicality of
the situation
good is that like when i went through
that like does that account
like is that something you get excited
about you're like no
that's cool for you gary but this one
variable with how i am
would make it need to be this i'm just
curious
no that makes sense that makes sense you
can't um
it's almost like i can feel that if
there were rules or
responsibilities put in place that
defied this freedom of like no
hours thing um it would be confusing
correct if you know because that's right
you nailed it that's such a good job
because if you've got them on the books
for 50 hours
but you want them to feel like there is
no hours
what they're feeling from you is oh you
want me to work 71 hours
yeah whereas if you're like no no we're
a crew and oh by the way
and i'm here more for you than you for
me because oh by the way
a million people want to be on team
garyvee but i'm picking you
and i want you to win and nothing would
make me happier than if you did this for
four years and then you became
you know p diddy's person i don't care
what what or you want to become the next
gary like
you tell me what you want i work for you
and then all of a sudden when you work
for them all those
dreams of you wanting them to be like a
family
become a true reality because you're the
one with leverage so you're the one that
actually has to create
it if you were to give someone that you
hire a new directive so this cut this
could apply to the people that are
giving this directive or the people that
are even receiving it just to be
observant of whether or not the person
that they're working for
has this kind of style or even
like comes in the same you know universe
as
uh as as what you're gonna say but you
know is there something that you lead
off with
anytime you hire somebody is there a way
to set
set it up for the best success beyond
the circumstance itself with the right
people in place
that gets them in the mindset like the
garyvee mindset
what do you tell them i tell them that
i am only obsessed with reverse
engineering them and putting them in a
position to succeed because if they're
happy
and flourishing all that trickle-down
collateral will come
in what i'm trying to get out of that so
that i need them
to communicate to me i need them to know
that i won't fire them i won't fire
somebody else
they won't be scolded i won't
subconsciously make them my not favorite
communicate and i know you can't trust
me right away
right away but i will earn your trust
it's a very interesting game they walk
into my ethos and i'm spending the
meaning making them understand in the
first year i'm going to earn your trust
and i trust you from the second you walk
in
it's quite the game being a boss you
know it's what's really fun is
you know it's just my natural state i'm
not scared of somebody letting me down
it's like the bronx tale they just
expose themselves
you know there's that great [ __ ]
telltale sign
um oh there's a million
you know which one pisses you off the
most which one are you like
you someone someone someone that is
thinks they're tricking me and are being
mean to everyone else
so they're being mean but they're trying
to they think they're delivering for me
and they're making money or they're
hiding it
and i'm happy because they're doing
great but meanwhile everybody underneath
them
hates them and they actually think it's
working because i haven't fired them yet
and the reason i haven't is because i'm
crossing my t's and eyes
because my companies are in london new
york and la and i have litigation and
lawsuits and
you know i just want to make sure we do
this properly but guess what sally
you're going
because if you're not kind and nice to
others and you're letting your
insecurity manifest
you're in deep [ __ ] with me
that is that fear and love that i i love
i love that right you're in deep [ __ ]
but i love the [ __ ] out of you and i'm
gonna treat you
i'm gonna earn your respect this year
i've already given it to you on the
front end
that's that beauty even when even when i
fire that manipulator
it ends with hey on the flip side you
have some great talents
and i know you're only doing this
because you're hurting inside let me
help you with your next chapter i'll
co-sign you
i'll put you know i'll help you maybe a
lot of these people tend to need to
start their own businesses because
they're not good teammates
but they're good nomads so there's just
a lot of things like that um
i don't get the feeling like you other
than michael jordan
and tom brady i guess i feel like you
don't hate anybody
not us i hate people that are advocates
of hate
um and sell fear and other than because
and try to hurt people
but to your point in like real life not
ideological like conversation
i really struggle to hate people it's
it's just
it's a complete waste of time um
i always like to ask people what their
greatest life lesson's been and i know
that you started off with you know
a pretty a pretty uh i've got one pretty
good situation but no but i've got one
i've such gift the gap that in my early
years i was so like poor
i would i was hustling kid like i was
willing to do whatever it took for the
book
you know like you know i would tell my
friends buy this card he's gonna be a
great player even though i didn't
believe it i had it in me
and my dad this is where my dad gets his
big you know
injection on my story my dad's got
a lot of shortcomings that i don't
appreci i don't agree with from a people
standpoint but i got to change him over
20 years together in the store but he
changed me he said
your word is bond and i was scared of my
dad at 14.
and he he basically
scared the [ __ ] out of me
and and honestly annika i i would argue
it might have been the most important
component because i was gifted with all
the other stuff
had i seen that part through you know
i'm aware that some people when they
first see me on social and things that
nature like this guy's full of [ __ ] like
because i've got that kind of like i get
it
um it's either love or hate right like
if i do not
tend to get neutral when people see
their first video you know and so
and i always think back to is that
because in a lot of ways that was there
and oh my god thank god as a child i was
able to be
put on the straight straightened
straight which is like do not use your
gift for bad
it's not what my dad meant he just hates
lying and so
um but it really helped me boy when i
again my second kind of emotional moment
like
[ __ ] man if he wasn't in my life and
didn't really
if i didn't you know it's your dad right
and like like
i don't i think i wouldn't be where i am
today in the same capacity because i
would have had some of the shortcomings
that come along with a great gift of gab
person which
leads to [ __ ] which leads to less
upside i don't think i would be admired
as much
i don't think i'd be as happy as much i
don't think i'd be happy with myself as
much and i think that's the punchline so
i think that was the greatest lesson
because that was actual lesson delivered
in a very simple way
it was a two-minute conversation um and
it
it changed my life in hindsight it's
beautiful thanks gary
thanks for having me on thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button